said frankov he was just called up the
other day he pitched a couple years in
korea he's only had three major league
appearances in his big league career so
juan soto is going to come up here with
runners on
first and third and nobody out
soda 263 two doubles three homers 12
batted in
as the tall right-hander frank off comes
set kicks and delivers and soto chops it
over the mound toward the middle of the
infield and coming in the second baseman
van meter has only one play to first in
time to get soto as turner comes in to
score harrison will go to second and
soto has his 13th run batted in the year
on the chopping ground ball the
nationals lead one to nothing with a
first down of the inning here's the guy
who's feeling well at the plate kyle
schwarber
here's the pitch and that's a swingy
strike three schwarber out first
strikeout for frankoff now two odds of
that runner still at third
here's starlin castro
caster on the ground down to third
escobar scoops it up
fires to pavement smith for the on a
pretty nice job they're getting out of
that mess with only the one on scoring
that play went five to three one run
the nationals were there two straight
wins right now 15 and 19. we'll see if
the nationals can keep things going with
joe ross on the mound here tonight
it's second and third here with nobody
out for the d-packs and the banner is
going to be eduardo escobar
well it's escobar time eduardo has
really got to get the bat going he's got
to be a key figure for the diamondbacks
offensively he's knocked in 20 but his
batting average right now sits at 200.
it's been like a big roller coaster for
him really struggled out the right out
of the gate
and then he got hot really hot and now
he's back to the struggle part there's a
shot to left center a base hit one is in
smith here comes rojas right behind
d-back slated 2-1 on three consecutive
hits off
joe ross here in this first inning
now van meter batch with two on and
still nobody out three balls two strikes
and the pitch
in there strike three called caught him
looking at a slider coming in from the
outside and van beeters run up that's
the first out of the inning
just down partial the catcher
this will be pitch number 19 of the
first inning for ross and it's grounded
back through the box
in the center field to base it escobar
will score heading to third base now the
throw goes over there and marshall hunts
his way into second
zelvia base in he took second on the
throw to third it's three nothing
diamondbacks
so frankos gotta feel a
and now the pitch swinging he chops it
toward third slow roller charging in
castro and overhand throwing a bell in
time for the outs the inning is over
here's the guy the diamondbacks couldn't
get out last night but one time john
gomez who went five for six in the ball
game frank off ready and the pitch swing
gonna miss he strike him out that one
had a little bit more slide to it and a
little bit more juice and he gets a
strikeout his second strike out one out
of the other victor robles coming up
nationals hoping robles get his back
going
as he bats again out of the number nine
spot in the order
slightly open stance knees slightly bent
and now the pinch hit on the ground
sharply up the middle a base into center
field bell is around third he's coming
home here comes the throw by heath it is
cut off
at the bound
as bell scores on a single to center by
victor robles driving in his fourth run
of the year
and the nationals draw a little closer
it's now arizona three and washington
two
turner doubled down the left field live
in the second pitch of the ball game
tonight he homered on the second pitch
of the ball game last night
a look back at robles frankoff's pitch
got him looking strike three and turner
knew it third strikeout came in with a
fastball painted the outside corner got
him looking wander under the ending on a
pair of hits in a and left we go to the
bottom of the second david smith leads
off against joe ross haven smith look
very comfortable his first at-bat so joe
ross is trying to get him get his feet
moving a little bit which is great
then he goes fastball away
and maybe his heart was in it but his
backside couldn't get him out there
josh van meter called on strikes first
time
uh let's make it twice
great run back action by joe ross
and here comes escobar with two on and
two men out
good time for a gapper
smith will run off second rojas off
first with two down 3-2 on escobar
ross is ready
out of the stretch here's the pitch
swing and a high fly ball deep right
field back of the warning track at the
wall have a night eduardo a three-run
shot he's driven in five and the
diamondbacks lead it six to two
there's a shot of some offense the
d-backs needed
escobar coming through again his fifth
rbi tonight
it scores smith in front of him and
rojos in front of him diamondbacks up
four
six to two here so they're loaded now
with two outs
schwarber is the batter
young has got him set up no balls two
strikes schwarber is one for one with a
home run off
alex young won a ball game in washington
earlier this season the pitch swinging
gonna miss he struck him out so
young gets revenge and schwarber slams
his bat or excuse me his helmet drops
his gloves at the plate and his bat and
young gets out of trouble with a
strikeout to end the ending they leave
him loaded so first and third now with
one out for nick
got the start and center tonight now
facing the lefty
and the first one to him from clay
swinging to miss the ball gets away and
a run will score
fall into the dirt he chased it coming
in as van meter to make it a 7-2 ball
game and on the play ahmed advances to
second on the wild pitch here's the set
and the 2-2 pitch swung on and hit on
the ground left side cut off by castro
they'll throw to first to bell
in time for the out as ahmed goes to
third and a chance to get yet another
run this inning if
andrew young can deliver with two out in
a runner at third
boys he delivered a couple of pitch
under home runs already this season had
a two hit game last night
neither was a home run he was he had
four hits on the season going into last
night's ball game and all four were
homers
big one against the nationals previously
there's a shot back up the middle center
field to base it in to scores ahmed
ander young delivers another pitch hit
this time of an rbi single to make it an
8-2 ball game
now josh bell to the plate three balls
two strikes to count
and a ground ball back toward the middle
diving stop by escobar throws to first
and they got him eduardo on the right
side of the infield look at ahmed
with that escobar who made a diving stop
there got up quickly and fired to first
and peyman smith helped him out with the
throw all right two ounces per all to
david's got to hit tonight one for three
the 1-1 pitch with two outs from suero
peralta swings down the right field line
got a shot
and it is gone a home run for peralta
second of the night for the d-backs 9-2
for peralta number four on the year rbi
number 28. boy david peralta drilled
that ball
107.6 miles an hour
here's trey turner
inside target from varsho the 2-1
swinging a ground ball to short this
will bring in a run ahmed scoops it on
the backhand and throws out turner at
first
for the second out of the inning
trey picks up rbi number 19 scoring
robles
it's now 9-3 diamondbacks
2-1 and two-out another lefty now for
man to play it's kyle schwarber
three balls two strikes on schwarber
with two on and two out the pitch for
manipulate
got him looking
third time tonight schwarber has struck
out this time called out on strikes and
they get is eduardo escobar another
crack at
a bat
swinging a shot to right is this another
yeah two tonight seven rbis for escobar
11-3 diamondbacks have a night eduardo
that ball was shot out of a cannon
and a couple hard hit balls and that's
another
blast to really cap off a nice night for
edward
so now here's juan soto
3-1 de soto chopped on the ground again
into the shift way out in right field
fielded by the second baseman laba and
he won't have a play turner scores from
third harrison goes to third it'll be a
base hit for soto
and rbi is second to the game in 14th of
the year
and it's now arizona 11 in washington
four now they're loaded for bell
bases loaded two outs
11-4 d-backs 3-2 pitch to josh bell
and a fly ball
left field side long run for peralta has
he got a play foul ground he's got it
and the diamondbacks secure the win here
tonight washington gets one to the ninth